[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
battle royale for championship where are
we dropping boys
same as always the highest point on the
map yes the ideal location
to be good at home but never win
conference two mountains
go cow town oh yeah legendary chest
we're finally gonna get the king's first
victory royale
nope just great guns and a note from
vladi saying he traded away all the good
stuff
what did the lakers get purple and go
we've got a sweet load out here yeah but
for once we got to cut the crap and play
together
hey where's ben over here mate i'm a
bush
please get out of the bush ben no it's
perfect camouflage
i'm 50 point guard 50 power forward
100 bush damn it ben no one wants to
play with a bush camper
right joelle joelle he's in the bush
with me now
come on in al if you want to be part of
the process
you've got to be part of the bush where
the heck is hardin
i swear all he cares about is getting
the latest skins
check it out hottest skin in the game
private westbrook reporting for duty
with the knock worst pickaxe i gotta
have a word with my guy at the item shop
okay suerte things are looking good the
storm is closing in and giannis will
never make it
i don't know i heard he can eurostep the
entire island
that's impossible no one can
only three steps not a travel
this should have been mine well kawhi i
guess there's only two teams left in the
battle for the west
no there's not beef balls the skin isn't
even available right now
no way russ can beat this one check it
out
beef boss with a dog backpack and the
dog
has a dj horn
wise investment of v-bucks and don't
forget nugget or milwaukee
we control the east and this attractive
bush
we've got to get closer joelle i can
only shoot from within three feet
[Music]
whoa what's going on i'm afraid we had a
technical glitch
sorry guys but the game's over for now
we have to reboot
reboot so what happens now we're all
going to disney world
really some of us are going to disney
world
[Music]
[Applause]
you